all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts
while I do my makeup or my hair
or drink coffee it just depends on the
day before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
guys
I'm officially a quitter and back on
coffee I think I've told you guys this
but
I just feel like it should be known and
it's really unfortunate because it's in
my intro video for my shows
and every show I just need to be
reminded
that yes ma'am you
you're a coffee drinker now you quit
all right before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and let's get started
so
I was scrolling on Twitter today
and I always see these Trad girls
talking about how they want to be a
farmer's wife
and like have a farm and live and do
what my thought is okay and I think this
and this is no shade to them
have you any of you ever actually lived
on a farm
because I promise you
it is not all you it's cracked up to be
okay like I grew up on 40 acres I didn't
grow up on a real farm
but my grandparents were farmers and I
grew up and I I had to raise chickens
and ducks and does anyone know how much
work chickens and Ducks are and this is
just chickens and Ducks okay
none of you none of you ladies are gonna
live on a farm if you're living in the
city now
and you didn't grow up with a farm I
promise you
you do not want to because I've spent
some time with the Amish in northern
Wisconsin okay I see what they do every
day trust me
this Farm life is not what you guys
think it is not but you know hey that's
just my two cents I just see it I'm like
have any of you done any actual farm
work
because I have it it is minimal okay and
I'm like okay what
oh I just I just have questions that's
it
so yesterday was a crazy day
yesterday was a crazy day so sneako
I'm about to
call it a day right so I went to this
Bitcoin thing
um
because my cousin is in Miami and I'm
filming this video about Bitcoin because
I know nothing about bit Bitcoin and I'm
getting look at orange skirt orange
pills
now
I don't know anything
but he took me to this like Christian
little Bitcoin thing it was kind of cool
fun right whatever and
um
this is very dark
she was lighter in here and sneako
messages me that I can come on a stream
yesterday
and I'm thinking
okay what what the hey
so I go on a stream
and it was crazy I got on this show with
the world's biggest streamers I was like
sneako you are doing me a real hold up
I'm trying to make it lighter sneako
you're doing me a real solid right now
because I got on with Aiden Ross I got
on with Gideon I think yeah I think
that's how you say it and I got on
with Mike something the guy on Logan
Paul's podcast
whatever dude's name is I forget
okay
so
what happens all right
well Gideon I think was trying to like
flirt or whatever with me and I was just
like ah I I feel really like awkward
just it's like a stream
I don't know
um
and then I did because I wild it a
little bit I did a wrap I did a
freestyle rap about Abba and preach I
know
I know I I wasn't sure if I was gonna do
it because I've been told you know
you need to just stop not do anything
because they just they're grown men they
just go after people they're like a
little gossip Channel let them gossip
you know but but
my producer said I could I looked at
blessing he was there and I said
blessing should I do it he said do it
don't tempt me because I will all right
so I did a little a little
wrap but the funniest part was
Mike tweeted at me a while ago I was
actually so excited that I triggered him
this is a couple months ago when I put
strippers on okay I'm gonna tell you the
back story behind this tweet a couple
months ago
I thought it was so crazy how my tweets
were going viral by tweeting the most
basic thing so I would be like strippers
or like what is the definition of
a stripper and then I said only
fans models are and literally
this stuff just went stupid viral I'm
like
the internet is so funny and this is
when I was newer on Twitter so I was
like
wow I love this Twitter place I could
just put basic thoughts and they go
viral I'm like I love it here
now
Mike tweeted it and I forgot what he
said I thought he called me a but
he corrected me on stream he said hey I
don't use that word sorry Mike I didn't
mean to I knew it was some sort of
insult but he said like so are you horn
on Twitter for likes or you know
something like that I tried to find the
Tweeter but I couldn't remember
I was thinking a bit rude a bit rude but
I'm like okay
tweeting taking off money or closed on
the internet
is this the same are we really gonna
Pretend This was the same but we
actually had a good convo I like him
he's a cool guy I've always liked him I
was actually excited I triggered him
I mean that's what I do I'm a traegerer
you know
but
it was crazy how this the decision to go
on sneako's stream
it's like you never know what it's going
to lead to
okay wait oh gosh
this is why you guys don't want to be a
girl
next thing person I triggered
oh
the Christians are going for me right
now it was crazy okay I was talking
about in this video how you have a hard
time talking to Christians because they
kind of like you can't ask any questions
without them being like ah like they get
mad same with the most anything it's
just the religion topic like I'm a
pretty open-minded person
hence I have the show I talk to people
that disagree all the time
and
I can like have a conversation with
someone
but I forgot he was talking about some
opinion I had with cheating and I'm
gonna do a whole thing on Church stuff
but some guy
was talking about how cheating was wrong
and then he lies on his title and said
that I denounced Christianity when in
the video I said I liked church I said I
think it was a good thing I just have
certain questions you know
and
yeah I was like okay he proved my point
because I was like see
Pearl has questions about Christianity
him lies
Pearl denounces Christianity
but it's it's kind of crazy you guys
will see it like I am the content maker
so I make the content and all the TMZ
reaction channels see this is another
another instance of fake
journalism TMZ TMZ media saying I said
things I didn't say
that I did things I didn't do
so I'd like to say here I do not
denounce Christianity I think that
feminism has infiltrated Christianity
and a lot of these preachers only preach
to women
that's it they never preach the man's
side of it and once you guys see this
they can't you can't unsee it it should
be equally wrong to withhold sex from
your husband and equally frowned upon as
it is to cheat
and they never have that conversation
why are they cheating they will never
point the finger at the wife they'll say
well
he should have left he should have left
this horrible contract that's like the
worst thing ever or the woman can take
your stuff in your kids he should have
just left
even if the wife wasn't sleeping with
him which I've interviewed divorce
attorneys on this that is a big reason
that happens a lot in marriage
two three-year sexless marriages whose
fault is that that's really really
common
but why do the preachers never preach
about it and that's like my question for
the religious people I'm not trying to
come at them but why do they always take
the woman's side the woman's point of
view
I'll do a whole thing on this but
Ting I denounced Christianity because
it's like that's that's a that's lying
La I just have questions
and then it's like how does this person
right maybe I'm turned off as a whole
okay they're gonna say I said things I
didn't say when I try to have a
conversation why would I continue to
have a conversation
and then in the same breath they'll say
they're going in in good faith
Am I Wrong maybe maybe I misinterpreted
it
I watched a bit of the video the video
wasn't so bad but I saw the title and
I'm just like
the cheaters have no morals yeah you are
saying I said things I didn't say unfair
fake news journalism anyways guys like
the video on your way out go check out
sneako stream okay you just type in
sneako on Rumble it'll come up
I think it should be up by now
there's gonna be Clips coming like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell I'll
talk to you next time